okay so we're going to show you parts to
the community inshah those wh in if that
M does come who you be providing for
come this
way this is o Road so this is you know
the road at hand in which has all the
shops has all the businesses has all the
activities so effective it'll be for the
people of that community
[Applause]
so soal you know this is oxb Road and
you know we can see a fair amount of you
know Muslim
businesses s you know restaurants and
what have you that mid in Fury you know
will serve the people of this community
all the way back to you know the green
down to active so it's in that given
sense you know in that given sense it's
something far reaching for the community
and alhamdulillah you know just having
that will be a basis for learning will
be a basis for
cultivation yeah it'll be a basis for
youth activity sorry about that
obviously we got a lot of bikers around
there we drive this mallah it'll be
basis to schooling youth activities
workshops and you know this is what you
need for a thriving Community that's
growing you know we got a lot of people
coming from all over the Gaff to West
Lon why because it's Cosmopolitan it has
all sorts to offer you know you've got
shopping centers and that's what you
want to bring you know when we do the da
table the da table Al is by westfi so
when we do that da we're meeting people
from all over the Globe it's
International we got people come from
Europe the Middle East you know the Far
East China so having a Masid yeah having
a Masid will serve the purpose of
bringing them back to a hub and then
showing them the resources and showing
them how we you know operate as a team
by so like I mentioned you know this is
the up road down here
you know we got all sorts got Algerian
Moroccan Somali you know rever mixed
race polish all sorts of people alhamd
we serve not just one Community a whole
Community it's an International
Community Muslim non-muslim so that's
what we're trying to do for the people
that are wondering uh maybe we'll give
you a bit more a bit further down the
line
okay this isun in she Bush uh this is
the main upstage road so a lot ofun in
terms of those that pray at the MOs
they're from this sort of you know
vicinity alhamdulillah you know we've
got alhamdulillah a lot of Muslim
businesses that opened up and also know
other sorts of businesses that are out
there but for you guys that are donating
inshallah this is what effectively
you're putting your money into you know
this is the this is effectively the
investment of in where your money will
Ro so you can see who you're serving you
know what did he say you
know you know any form of goodness is a
form of Charity even if it be a penny
even it be you know a smile of any sort
this is what you're effectiv
serving this community people
around it's a long strip
the yeah we got a lot of Muslim
businesses Somali brother you know
alerian brother all sorts of
Multicultural as I mentioned in the last
video Multicultural and that's what we
serve it's not just one race it's not
just one particular type of people even
non-muslims Sometimes they come to the
mam alikum brothers and sisters my name
is ABD rman been Muslim now for nearly
years
alhamdulillah right now is looking for a
new message as when you go there what
you will find is outside it's messy
there people drinking alcohol people
doing
drugs um this is a beacon call calling
towards the Quran and the Sunnah one of
the few places call towards the actual
Quran actual authentic Sunnah age of
Buddhas the
prophet mentioned that Allah AIDS the
slave so long as he AIDS his brother so
Aid your brothers through Dua through
finances to spreading this message May
bless
you my name is this is my brother RI
we've been coming to this madasa for
over a decade now and we
learned and made a lot of good brothers
and we we form lots of good brother
brotherhoods and bonds of the brothers
here yeah big Community was started of
small alhamdulillah over 10 years we've
been here came madasa here when we were
little grew throughout um alhamdulillah
very close to our teachers now um it's
been a journey alhamdulillah now such um
it's been it's so pack now that it's
it's hard to fit people in for J and
events like uh conferences like Shi
holds it gets really packed so inshallah
if we can raise our Target
amount brothers and sisters my name is
abar I am from Koso originally and live
in Belgium although I live in Belgium I
have visited in many in more than one
occasion my first time my first time I
couldn't believe that I was going to the
Masjid when I was walking through the
alleyway uh when I reached the the the
mosque the first time I thought is this
it like is this the Masjid it's really
tiny small small
Masjid
uh so the the Masjid is so so so small
and yet they still have a curtains to
give to to give access to the sisters to
come to to worship Allah and to benefit
from the many lessons that they
deliver uh alhamdulillah even though I
don't live anywhere near near uh near it
I still benefit from their lessons
online may Allah bless them and reward
them the brothers definitely definitely
need and deserve a better better
location and a better place
[Music]
inallah Ramadan is here
and we ask Allah within this month to
accept our duas our salaat our fasting
and as you know it's a month of Good
Deeds it's a month in which inshallah by
way of these Good Deeds you will draw
closer to your lord nearest to Allah
waala so let's not forget the campaign
that we at Mah are campaigning for that
we hope inshallah by way of your
donations from the community and anyone
else out there that we can have a better
place for the Muslims a place in in
which you can learn a place in which you
can cultivate the young the individuals
at hand that are in need of most of the
help that we can get and as the
messenger
said whosoever builds a house for Allah
then Allah will build him a house in
Paradise let's not forget that one of
the seven people that will be shaded
on
is is that the young boy he who is you
know cultivated and brought up in the
Masid he will be under the shade of
Allah but you can't really implement
this Hadith unless you have a Masid in
all fairness so this is one of the
reasons why we ask Allah and likewise
you guys out there they have the ability
to carry on donating it's a month from
which inshallah you'll be rewarded
greatly as you
know yes it's the month in which this
Quran was revealed so likewise we should
carry on contemplating of the verses of
allaha and not stop in doing good deeds
because this could be last Ramadan could
be my last Ramadan and we want to make
it count inshallah as we all know that
true investment which is the investment
of the after
[Music]
life for